-Our first guest tonight i
an Emmy Award-winning comedian
who you know from his 18 seasons
on "Saturday Night Live"
and his fantastic series
"Kenan."
Please welcome back to the sho
one of the all-time best.
Kenan Thompson, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
In the studio.
-In the studio.
-In the stooge.
What's up, my dudes?
I thought it was
gonna be a while
since I saw a lot of these guys.
-Have you ever been
in front of this many people
at once?
-This is incredible.
-Isn't it?
-Hello, hello, hello, hello.
I love it.
-Take a set.
-Which one? Are we still
having to six-foot it?
-No, you can do this now.
We're doing this now.
-Oh, that's gangster.
-Not bad, right?
-What's happening around here?
-Look at us.
Like a regular TV show.
-We got the whole studio.
-Now, you're filling in for us
Thank you so much.
Our friend Luke Wilson had t
cancel at the last minute,
and you scrambled over here.
Now, I will say,
there was one person
who was a little upset
that you're here.
-Oh, who's that?
-Wally, who you know well
from "SNL."
Wally was our last time
fill-in guest.
-What's up, Wall-oo?
-Hey, buddy.
-He just assumed this would be
an all-time thing.
-Oh, man. I'm sorry.
Did I crash your parade
a little bit?
-If anybody was gonna replac
me, I'd rather it be you.
-Yeah, sure, sure, yeah.
-Yeah.
And, again, I need to stress
you don't have a say in it
-Oh.
-I was just about to say.
Who's really got the power here,
by the way?
-Wally, of course, does -- Wally
does have the power, of course
You and I both learned how
to do cue cards from Wally
-I learned everything I know
about cue cards from Wally
-What did you guys do on you
early sketch days on "All That"?
-We memorized.
-Really?
-Absolutely.
We were kids who were unde
the heavy pressure
and foot
of the Nickelodeon legacy.
No, I mean, it's just like
they gave us --
-I like that the first day a
Nickelodeon, they were like,
"You will learn your lines."
-Yes.
"And you will learn French
and you will speak it."
They literally had me trying
to learn French
to do that character.
-That's Escargot?
-Yeah, that's Escargot.
And I was like,
"I'm gonna make this up."
-Wally, could you tell
right away Kenan was a pro
-Oh, yeah. Yeah.
He picked it up right away
-I'm sorry. I couldn't hear.
What was that?
-Well, it's hard because Wally's
speaking through two --
Do you know why Wally
has a sponge on his mask?
-Yeah, 'cause he likes to lick
his disgusting fingers
so he can turn the cards.
I get it, man.
When I'm counting bread,
when I'm counting money,
you know what I'm saying,
I do the same thing.
-The burn on Wally is, we don'
have to wear the masks anymore
but he can't figure out
how to get his sponge
on the paper mask,
so he's still wearing
the plastic mask
'cause of his finger problem
-It doesn't stick?
Isn't it just sticking
to the plastic?
-It's glued there.
So then if you glue it,
you'll be inhaling glue.
-Yeah.
-Hey, man.
Typical Friday night for Wally
-The weird thing is he say
he has to lick his fingers
to do the cards.
But I've watched.
He licks them,
then he dries them off,
then he does the cards.
-Oh, man.
-It's just a tick.
-What's going on there, bud?
Let's just focus in on thi
for a while.
-When Wally was here,
we talked about the time
that Charles Barkley
pulled the prank
where he pretended at rehearsa
to get mad at Wally.
-Yes.
-Do you remember that?
-I do remember that.
Also, like, one of the nices
human beings in the world.
-One of my favorite things
and this obviously happened more
for you at "SNL" than me
because you did
so many impressions.
Sometimes people
would host the show
that you had done
an impression of.
And I remember at the Monday
pitch when Barkley hosted,
you walked -- as everybody
was walking in,
he was like [As Charles Barkley]
"Where's Kenan?"
-[ As Charles Barkley ] "Com
on, sucker, do it to my face!"
[ Normal voice ]
"Alright, hello, Mr. Barkley
Good to see you, sir."
[ As Barkley ] "Yeah,
next time I'm going to give yo
one of these
knuckle sandwiches."
[ Normal voice ]
"Alright, yeah, sure.
Yeah, I'll take it."
But, yeah, no, he's great.
And I remember him, like,
trying to get everybody, like,
very enthusiastically
to go along
with this small prank
that he wanted to do.
-He just wanted
to yell at Wally.
-Yeah, it was.
[ As Barkley ]
"I think it'll be really funny
if we got mad at Wally
and then yell at him."
[ Normal voice ]
We're like, "Okay, cool."
Like, "Let's just do it."
And, you know, we improv
for forever sometimes,
especially Fred.
He'll just go for a day
and a half with a joke.
But Barkley broke it
after two seconds.
He was like [As Barkley] "Wally,
what the hell you doing?
I'm just playing, man.
Be my friend.
Just be my friend."
-It speaks
to what a good guy he is.
-Yeah, he's a sweet dude.
-You and I, obviously, have been
friends for a long time.
I was very happy about the fac
that you were at my wedding.
I was happier about the fact
that you rented a car.
-Oh, God, let me show you.
Here's a picture.
-This was very unique
to the location.
-Absolutely.
-I did not realize
it was even available to rent.
-Okay, so, you know,
not a lot of people
have destination weddings,
number one,
but let alone go to a wonderful,
you know,
isolated place
like Martha's Vineyard.
-Yeah.
-It's a beautiful place.
I had never been there
in my life.
And, you know,
I guess it's not known
for lots of black people
being there.
There is a certain sector
of them that go there.
-Yes, actually, I would sa
of New England
vacation destinations
it's most known for.
-Yeah.
But at the time, on the island
I think I was the only one
And the only rental car
that they had left
that was like semi-cool
was a bright yellow
convertible Camaro.
And so, yeah, I was just driving
around, me and my wife.
And she took this picture of us,
with me wearing
this bright red --
And for some reason,
my eyes are half closed.
But I'm just having
a grand old time just dri-
And people were shouting out
my name and stuff like that.
I thought I was much more
low-key than that,
but I guess I was standing out
like a sore thumb.
-I'm worried we've told
this story on the show before,
but I had the pleasure onc
of driving with you.
We did a stand-up show togethe
at University of Rhode Island.
I said, "Kenan, it's the best.
We'll take Amtrak."
We get there.
Amtrak's closed.
Like, that train is canceled
-They canceled the train.
-And so we went
to get a rental car.
And at the time, I did not
have a driver's license,
and you did not have
a credit card.
-Right.
-And they were very insisten
that we couldn't combine the two
to rent a car.
-Yeah, meanwhile,
clock is ticking.
It's approaching.
-Yes.
-'Cause it's
an hour-and-a-half drive?
-No, it was a longer drive
than that.
I think it was like
a 3 1/2-hour drive.
-So it's already after 5:00.
Show was starting
at like 7:30-ish?
-Yeah, we were gonna
have to hustle.
And then you -- I said,
"Can we talk to a manager?
Which I've never done before
And I will say,
it's very empowering.
-"May I speak to the manager
please."
-Yeah.
And the manager came out.
And do you remember what
she said when she saw you?
-She asked --
It took a minute.
She was like, "Okay,
what's going on here?"
And it was like, "Well, ma'am.
I think you were talking to her.
It's like, "Well,
we're trying to rent a car
but I don't have
a driver's license
and my friend doesn't have
a credit card."
And then she looked over
and saw me.
"Hey, baby, oh, y'all good
Go on and take it.
Take these keys."
I think she gave us
a very nice car immediately.
-I couldn't believe it.
It was nothing.
There was like nothing.
It was like, "I can't do this.
And she saw you --
-I was her son, basically.
Like, "Oh, yeah, baby,
go on to the prom.
Take this car.
Have a good time.
This your date?
Y'all have fun.
I don't judge."
-And then you drove.
By the way, I think it was
we were 3 1/2 hours away,
and we had to make it ther
in 2 1/2 hours.
And you drove so fast, we stil
had like an hour to spare.
-Yeah, and I just remember
a moment where I was like,
"Oh, I'm doing the most for Seth
right now."
Because it was
a two-lane highway,
and then there was two cars,
and I ended up going in betwee
the middle of them.
And just watching Seth
do like this was just --
Mm, if I could have filmed it.
That was a beautiful --
-But we did make it.
-Yeah, we made it.
-And that was a good time.
Before you go --
And thank you again for coming
over here and bailing us out
-Buddy, it's my pleasure.
I want to run through
the audience.
-Kenan, your sitcom got picked
up for a second season.
You're gonna start
shooting that.
-It sure did.
-Congratulations, buddy.
-Thank you very much.
-I am in awe of the fact tha
you both did "SNL" this year
you also did the first seaso
of a wonderful sitcom,
and also father
to two beautiful girls.
So it must have been
a real balancing act.
But you just pulled it off
with aplomb.
-Thank you, man.
Thank you.
It was a real hustle, you know
And luckily, I'm going from on
loving environment to the other.
You know, like, I've been here
for 18 years of my life no
at this point.
And then going over to our new
built family over there
with the great Don Johnson
and Chris Redd,
you know what I mean, like
just my brother in tow.
Like, you know,
as tired as I was,
I knew Chris was going through
the same thing at least.
You know what I'm saying?
So I never felt alone.
But also, I was just going
from one big hug to the other,
so it was a real pleasure.
-Well, it paid off, buddy.
And it is always a pleasur
to see you.
That's Kenan Thompson,
everybody.
We'll be right back
with Juno Temple.